[Music]
you know one of the oldest questions I
think humankind is asked is if there's
other life in the universe is it very
very different from us or is it very
similar and you know even when it comes
to the microbial level even like very
small like bacteria things you know
right now we're exploring the solar
system looking for evidence of life on
Mars or on some of the icy moons of
Jupiter and Saturn there there oceans
underneath the ice and even if we found
a microbe I think one of the first
questions is does it have something like
DNA is it similarly put together the way
we are or is it something very different
even at the microbial level and then you
take that question and you move even
farther I mean what would aliens that
are more evolved look like aliens that
maybe even have advanced civilizations
and this is one of these things where
I'm very aware of the limits of human
imagination you know I mean Einstein
famously said you know the universe is
not stranger than we do imagine it's
stranger than we can imagine and I think
that a lot of times people say well we
have one evidence of how life started
and how life can exist and it sort of
makes sense that maybe something similar
would have started on on different
planets I think actually when when you
when you think about civilizations
aliens out there that are advanced that
maybe even have more advanced
civilizations than we do the thing that
I really can't get around is that I
think that the definition of being human
is about to change a lot in the next
century I think that humans and AIS and
computers will begin to merge actually
become somewhat indistinguishable from
each other this is not some Terminator
scenario of the AIS taking over and
destroying everything but you know for
example I have a friend who has cochlear
implants he was profoundly deaf and then
had cochlear implants put in and I've
gone to classical music concerts with
him I remember I went to go see Carmen
and there were tears you know rolling
down his face as he was listening to
Carmen and he knows that he doesn't hear
like a human being hears there are wires
that are directly implanted into his
brain that stimulate the auditory
section it never goes through an ear and
he upgrades his software every now and
then and then he hears differently all
of a sudden the sounds are different and
he
here's different ranges depending on how
his software has been updated but it's
he always reminds me that what
technology did for him was make him more
connected more emotional I remember
somebody was colorblind but they
actually have an auditory cue as to
color and so it sort of changed the way
their brain responds the implants that
are coming and they will be coming soon
you know once you could implant
artificial ears and people why just here
with the range of a human right why not
here with the range of a dog or a whale
or a bird that can hear much higher and
lower pitch frequencies that we can that
will come soon and then when we can
augment our eyes why just see visible
light why not see x-rays and ultraviolet
and infrared light and everything that's
out there I don't think there's any way
around this that the aliens we're going
to encounter if they are advanced from
us by many centuries of technology are
going to be indistinguishable from a
eyes and I don't think we are looking
for a biological life I think we should
spend more time thinking about what life
really will evolve into it may be that
the biological being that I am was just
a first stage in evolution and a
necessary and and maybe even beautiful
next step in evolution is for us to be
augmented and maybe someday to
completely design our artificial bodies
when you design your own body to suit
any environment you want why look like a
human I mean maybe you want to maybe you
want to be a piece of foil that spreads
itself across you know square kilometers
to actually fly on solar winds and
actually move around through solar
systems maybe you look nothing like a
human maybe you have nothing like a
human life so this is not a scary
science fiction scenario I'm not saying
that we're going to be overrun and
destroyed by the AIS but I don't know
how you get around very advanced
civilizations having gone through an
augmentation stage and I think the next
stage in our evolution will most likely
be that and I think maybe we shouldn't
be looking in environments just like the
earth that maybe where life started but
truly evolved civilizations left that
that biological necessity behind long
ago as fury
but like I said this this guy his name
is Michael with the cochlear implants I
mean he's like you know why do we assume
technology's gonna keep us apart from
each other and make us less human it
might make us even more human
[Music]